yeah welcome to this five-minute game um
go I really hope I do better than in the
warm-up games I played to warm up games
and lost terribly and what is this guy
doing he's just blundered the rook with
this child childish trick or whatever
what well okay I decided to let it do a
video anyway and the heck with my form
and this guy just just blend us this
piece okay so let's let's wrap this up
this is really quite amazing um okay
still on how to win p 3 yeah maybe can
attack the pawn pawn chain here on c4 f6
prevented 95 but he doesn't have any a
great way to to continue here giving you
this check just play b-52 if it takes b3
i take p 5 threatening Queenie 6
yeah that's a new move coming rook c8
came ok I'll just take it and yeah what
he continues what what can you do Bishop
c4 simply so that's some drawback don't
see it Roxy 6i can go to a two
yeah I'll get to see one Bishop is also
hanging I cannot easily move the service
piece but I can always protect it with
92 so if he owes Quincy seven that's
just not be 2d to know just castling
getting out of the way yeah just define
no yeah let's let's open this position
frankly I'm not quite sure why are why
he is continuing maybe he saw the two
games I played before okay Queen
somewhere b3 b1 really doesn't matter
too much so I'm giving this check or
bishop to you form
John maybe we should treat for simpler
tending we should be too
yeah he's got some active pieces but
it's it's still two piece down
h7 is also hanging but I want to get out
of the pin yeah that's that the Sun I
think the simpler way to to play it
if you're a piss-up you can simply
exchange stuff don't need to worry about
them winning yet another porn or
something Bishop e3 let's get rid of
this active bishop
maybe we need to check yes Bishop d5
queen bee three check here also a
scalper should be five if I take first
and then give this check with what then
I just pick up yet another piece right
yeah this is really quite remarkable
that that someone actually with an
international Todd lord step into this
very well known that win over PCM yeah
well thanks for watching this video
anyway